nous joignons mais des victimes pour
pleurer la perte des nombreuses victimes
du vol 752 ukrainienne john h
c'est une tragédie nationale
hier soir l'iran a confirmé que de
manière inattendue ionel il avait abattu
le vol 752 il s'agit d'une situation
très grave
le canada et le monde ont encore bon
nombre de questions des questions
auxquelles il faudra répondre
un peu plus tôt ce matin j'ai parlé avec
le président rouhani de l'iran je lui ai
dit que la reconnaissance de l'iran que
ses forces armées avait deux manières
une antenne y intentionnel a battu le
vol 752 était une étape importante pour
fournir des réponses aux familles mais
j'ai noté qu'il y avait d'autres étapes
encore à franchir une enquête pleine
devra être mené à bien
nous avons besoin de faire toute la
lumière sur comment cette tragédie
horrible a eu lieu
les familles demandent de la justice de
la reddition de comptes
il faut leur en faire part j'ai répété
aux présidents rouhani qu'il est crucial
que le canada participe à cette enquête
nous nous attendons à la pleine
collaboration des autorités iraniennes
à l'heure actuelle 3 visas ont été
accordés pour les membres du groupe de
développe vraiment rapide
on s'attend à ce que les membres de ce
groupe arrive à teyran à 16 heures ce
soir et qu'il établisse une présence sur
le terrain pour aider les familles
canadiennes
d'autres membres de l'équipe suivront
nous travaillons avec nos homologues qui
sont en train de faciliter le processus
par lequel les visas sont octroyés les
iraniens sont en train de coopérer et de
fournir des visas président oignies j'ai
également condamné les frac iranien les
frappes iranienne menée en irak qui ont
mis en danger la vie de nos membres qui
combattent des ch
ainsi que ceux de la coalition j'ai
également répété l'appel du canada à la
dsk nation détention ainsi que notre
engagement à assurer la paix et la
sécurité dans la région
ce sont leurs des moments de tension
telle qu'en ce moment que de telles
tragédies telles que cet écrasement
peuvent avoir lieu en causant la mort
d'innocents
la réponse du président rouhani a été de
s'engager à collaborer pour pouvoir
désescalade et les tensions et continuer
le dialogue
nous allons continuer à miser sur la
reddition de comptes la transparence et
la justice pour les familles et les
êtres chers des victimes comme le
ministre champagne vous l'a dit hier
notre gouvernement va prendre des
mesures supplémentaires pour fournir
plus de succès aux gens dans le deuil
j'ai demandé au greffier du conseil
privé de mettre sur pied un groupe de
travail d'urgence qui s'est réunie plus
tôt aujourd'hui
de plus les agents consulaires et
d'immigration ont été déployés aux pays
pour qu'ils puissent contacter
directement les familles canadiennes
touchés par cette tragédie
le ministre mende chinois a mis sur pied
un numéro de téléphone d'urgence pour
que les fonctionnaires d'immigration
canada soit disponible s'il ya des
enjeux de traitement de visa
continueront d'être en contact avec tout
autre ordre de gouvernement pour faire
en sorte que les familles reçoivent le
soutien dont elles ont besoin
j'ai parlé à tous les chefs de
l'opposition ainsi que plusieurs
premiers ministres des provinces
affectées alors ce que les canadiens
traversent de grandes difficultés
ils se montrent solidaires des uns avec
les autres
face à la tragédie nous avons su être là
pour nos voisins nos communautés et nos
concitoyens je sais que cet élan de
compassion apporte du réconfort à ceux
et celles qui ont perdu un proche à la
suite de cette tragédie
mais sachez que notre gouvernement
n'arrêtera pas d'exiger des réponses aux
questions qui persistent
nous serons là je serai là pour veiller
à ce que la lumière soit faite sur ces
événements bouleversants
je reste en étroite collaboration avec
mes partenaires ainsi que les mines et
j'ai parlé avec le premier ministre et
ab du japon il est en chemin vers le
moyen-orient et je parlerai également
avec le président ukrainien céline ski
ainsi que le premier ministre et au lof
de la suède le ministre champagne parle
avec ses homologues en iran en suisse en
turquie en suède et en ukraine afin de
parler des progrès pour ce qui est de
l'émission du visa pour nos équipes
il va également avoir une autre demande
du groupe international de coordination
et de réponse pour les familles des
victimes du vol ps 752 afin de
coordonner notre réponse pour les
familles et ce de concert des
représentants de l'ukraine de la suède
du royaume-uni et de l'afghanistan qui
sont également en deuil s'est également
entretenu avec des autorités françaises
plus tôt aujourd'hui je vous assure que
toutes ces discussions se poursuivent
[Musique]
j'aimerais conclure en vous parlant un
peu de ce que j'ai fait hier
hier j'ai eu l'occasion de ma soeur et
que certaines des familles des victimes
ces personnes sont blessées elles sont
fâchés elles sont dans le deuil
elles veulent des réponses elles veulent
que la justice leur soit rendue
l'iran a admis un fait très grave
d'abattre un aéronef civile est un geste
horrible
l'iran doit en assumer la pleine
responsabilité
le canada ne s'arrêtera pas avant que
l'on nous ait rendu la reddition de
comptes et la justice est ce nécessaire
pour les familles c'est d'être des
nôtres ce matin